[Music]
where are we Joshua we're in Hannah
Hall's houseboat in Sausalito California
San Francisco is a bit of our happy
place we left it up there people keep
asking you know if I could live on a
houseboat no I couldn't either no no I
don't think you could oh I couldn't
[Music]
when writing this book I had a draft
that looked very unlike the story we now
know today and I remember you came into
the room and you said what if you think
about it a little bit differently when
you said that it helped me imagine a
different ending which is a prime
example sort of of how our writing life
works at home we read everything the
other writes if I had my way we would
sit in the same office all day we do a
lot you try to go to your secret office
it's supposed to be secret from our son
who found it who loves it loves it
good day at work better now that it's
over
felt very natural for us to start
writing the show together and you love
being on set I continue to learn so much
from you I'm used to adapting historical
pieces this is quite a departure
departure
adapting a historical event is hard
because there's a ton of research
whereas here we had this great book and
that was the huge help what I love about
your writing is it's so insightful and
thoughtful so all those episodes you
took the first pass on and I just
cleaned up around the margins you can do
all sorts of things in screenwriting
that I could never do though making this
world Visual and dual dialogue using
final draft all the things in some ways
it felt like I was going to film School
working with you
what time
I won't be safe anymore
not from anything
one of the things I always loved about
the book is that it is both this
suspense mystery but it is also a
meditation on parenting and found
families do you think you could have
written that before we had Jacob I don't
know this book is a love letter to Jacob
I always tell him it's his book which he
thinks the whole book's about him but in
some ways it is you are absolutely gonna
her and you know
me
it's been very nice to walk down memory
lane with you today I've adapted a bunch
of books but I've never gotten to adapt
a book written by my wife Laura which
has been a joy and I only hope I have
done it justice you did there's not a
whole lot you could tell me about that
would change anything between us well
thank God for that
[Music]